Speaker 1: one to just not spend a lot of time on
this. But I do want to show you one other clip.
A bunch of people wrote in asking me to talk about
this one. Former Trump national security adviser
Michael Flynn suggests that there is going to be
sort of like secret vaccination done of people by
putting the vaccine in salad dressing. He said he
heard that our friend John Amato over at Crooks
and Liars wrote this up. Michael Flynn is insane,
says vaccine, as in salad dressing. Michael
Flynn's latest crazy deep state spiking your salad
dressing with covid vaccine. This was on. I don't
even know what showed this was on. It looks to
be some kind of like bogus medical and financial
consultation type show the ads on the screen say
something about Protect Your Health. With her help
from Sherwood TV and meon M.D. Vladimir Zelenko,
MD. Protect your wealth with help from Andrews or
Quini. I don't even know where these where
do they even find these shows? I don't know.
But here is Michael Flynn talking about,
I guess, some kind of deep state putting
vaccine vaccines in salad dressing. Does drinking
the vaccine even do the same thing as injecting
it? It all sounds very stupid, but here's
Michael Flynn and you'll notice. So remember
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn. This was the top national security
official in the country for a short period
of time. He's also wearing a shirt that has
his own name on it. It says Flynn. It's weird.
Speaker 7: It's real. I mean, I got to put you
know, somebody sent me a thing this morning where
they're talking about putting the vaccine into
salad dressing or salads. Yes. I mean, it's and
I'm thinking to myself, this is the bizarro world,
right? This is definitely the bizarro world.
So there's the seriousness of what this
what this professional realized he was doing
wrong. And he and he's now he's found a new
way. And then there's this, the laugh ability
on the other extreme that people I mean, these
people are seriously thinking about how to impose
their will on us in our society. And and it's
Speaker 1: choice. Yeah. So there is no plan to
put the vaccine into salad dressing. But also,
I mean, I don't I don't know that
this is really even relevant, but
the people we would need to trick into taking the
vaccine. Are probably more likely to have it in a
hot dog than in a salad, if you understand what
I'm saying. So like if this was your approach,
I'd be looking at maybe injecting the vaccine
into a frankfurter rather rather than mixing it
into salad dressing. It just might take I think
the folks are more likely to reach for the dog
than the salad, but that's probably probably a
different issue. There is no such plan, of course,
and it's completely absurd. And who even watches
these shows? Like there's a lot of these shows
that are either religiously oriented financial
advice or religiously oriented medical advice or
just quackery, and they seem to get donations.
I don't know who is watching and who would who
would be watching in a serious way, like we
monitor these shows in a sort of satirical sense,
like like the horror of it. But somebody
must be contributing to this stuff and also.
If they get Michael Flynn on, maybe we
can get Michael Flynn on, right? I mean,
these shows don't seem to have much of an
audience. Maybe Michael Flynn would be willing
to appear with me. I would be glad to speak
to him. I think that would be absolutely great